it's the rainy season here in
northeastern Nigeria farmer Ghani
Abba has come out - sprays fields in
preparation for planting the new seed
crop Ghani has to be careful not to
stray too far out he always stays within
sight of the town of Ron kingdom come
we've had to abandon our outer fields
because of cocoa Haram it's safer here
but there's not enough land it's been a
while since goñi has been able to plant
anything at all
last year he lost count of how many days
his family had nothing to eat and he's
not optimistic about the coming year
either this will be a poultry harvest I
have two wives and nine children to feed
normally I need at least 40 sacks of
millet to make ends meet but look at
this country now I was lucky that my
grandfather left me this land my own
fields are too far away
militias keep watch over a roughly five
kilometre span around Ron but the poorly
equipped local troops can only provide
limited protection for farmers like
Dhoni
okay we patrol the area day and night
when we run into Boko Haram we fight
either we kill them or they'll kill us
we're not afraid of them even at night
if we see lights will go out to inspect
the consequences of fallow fields are
visible across the area mal nourishment
people dying from diseases that could
normally be treated quite easily and in
the rainy season washed out roads
limiting the amount of help aid
organizations can provide this is a
protection crisis which has gradually
turned into a food security and a
Nutrition crisis it's a very fragile
situation we are at the very peak of the
lean season waiting and hoping that
livelihood inputs and the agriculture
support providing farmers with seeds and
tools and fertilizers starting in June
is going to lead to a harvest that is
going to have an impact on the overall
situation on the ground but not everyone
is optimistic agricultural expert Abba
gumbo is critical of the government's
inadequate response he is calling for
more support for farmers as well as
sustainable food supplies you might give
the people the seed but then if you do
not give them food the seed you are
given to them will ultimately be used
for food because when you give a hungry
man for example 10 kilograms of millet
hybrid go to your famine plant and then
in the house he has two wives and about
seven children and the children are
crying for hunger tell me the manda will
have the heart not to give that ten
kilograms of millet to be grounded
immediately to be made into poori to
give to the boy
and then he forgoes the farm as long as
the fighting continues farmer going Abba
is certain food scarcity will continue
most of his neighbors don't have the
means to prepare their fields during the
rainy season this means yet another year
of being dependent on food donations
goñi is lucky to at least have enough
money for fertilizer all he wants is to
be able to provide for his family again